Danny is with us in Tennessee hi Danny
what's up
oh I'm just calling about a retirement
plan that me and my wife talked about
and we want to buy a house in Jekyll
Island why and I don't know if I need to
right go out there do a loan why do you
need to buy a house in Jekyll Island for
a retirement plan that's that's where we
want to live when we retire
oh don't you buy there when you retire
well I'm hoping to in three years from
now good good then my question is I've
got probably a half a million in 401 K
I've got 80 grand in savings in our
checking and I've got five rental homes
plus my own so should I sell one or two
of my rental homes and just actually
outright pay for it and Jeckle when you
get ready to move but I wouldn't do it
now you wouldn't do it now
no you're not moving for three years
correct
I was just gonna sit there empty for
three years well probably two or one and
a half and I'll take my vacation and
what long weekends I can go and update
it the way we want it well if you want
to if you want to some work to it buy it
in time to do the renovation before you
want to move into it so buy it six
months early but I wouldn't buy three
years early you don't want a three-year
renovation project that's not fun well
I'm in the construction business so
that's why I'm asking okay if you want a
three-year renovation project you can do
that that's not fun to me okay I can't I
can't imagine that being pleasant for
your wife oh honey let's go to Thailand
I'm gonna swing a hammer all weekend
while you smell sawdust I doubt it well
but let me ask you this should I sell
one or two of my rental homes and
outright pay for it or take a personal
loan out of the bank
I don't borrow money so what I'm going
to do is to set you up in retirement
that free so how much how much money do
you owe on these rentals anything okay
right now like I said I've got 500 in my
401k got a bank I got that and 80 in the
back and we've got five rentals what are
you owe on the five rentals uh I really
don't know but I clear after everything
is said and done about $2,200 a month
okay well the equity is all that matters
the $2,200 won't be there when you start
selling them so what will the house and
Jeckle cost what do you plan to spend
there I'm looking at maybe two to twenty
five and then put another 100 grand and
and just update and everything okay so
you want 300 fifty thousand dollar house
and Jeckle that in terms of what you put
into it
what were your personal residence so for
when you get ready to move to jackal
okay right now my house is worth 340 and
I owe 140 okay so there's two hundred of
your 350 we need another 150 to pay cash
for Jeckle when you go into retirement
and I've got one of my rental houses
that I own in my neighborhood that I owe
roughly 40 on and I could sell it for
170 okay they weren't eight there we're
getting there
so if you sold your house in that house
you could pay cash for Jekyll Island and
you'd still have five hundred eighty
thousand dollars plus your other four
rentals correct and we want to get those
paid off as quickly as we can during the
time that we're working towards
retirement all the data tells us that
we've got to that as you go into
retirement your highest probability of
becoming wealthy and staying wealthy is
debt-free and continuous investing those
are the two things we find when we just
study millionaires and so I'm not going
to Jack on and putz around over there
and you know mess around and tie up a
bunch of money and borrow a bunch of
money and pay a bunch of interest so I
have a weekend project for three years
pay cash for the property when you buy
it by selling off enough rentals pay
cash for the renovation and you can
replenish
some of your cash if you need to with
the sale of your personal residence when
you do finally make the move to Jekyll
into a debt-free property that you're
going to live in the rest of your years